[Music]
we're going to talk about an emotional
support squirrel we're going to talk
about some news from the DC comic
universe but first check this out
this is a video from Twitter twitter
user then Wesson Thank You Gillian so
this took over Twitter show that tweet
from Chrissy Teigen and saying the only
Little Caesars I want to go to this is
one of my favorite videos in a while
classic little actually I've never been
into but I've never been in a only
remember it from elementary school if
you read like three books you got like
you know a coupon for Little Caesars
they make like square pizzas and stuff
anyway so like this is clearly a hoax
they're not serving date or no they
didn't serve DiGiorno pizza no Little
Caesars they have some standards
shopping standards there's Starbucks
inside those types of brand loyal until
the day you'd have to order to order
exactly what's on that frozen pizza you
like some green pepper I want to put a
pepperoni that's like on the crust
that'll follow hey you know the Caesars
will win hands down but I will say this
pizza is the best of the pizza
disagreement Lucy's will win does your
dough makes a better pizza
answered this show I would need a full
DiGiorno pizza every episode no I might
disrupt the conversation but the journos
if you're watching I will eat a full
DiGiorno's pizza every single anyway I
will eat a full DiGiorno's pizza every
episode if you sponsor this show it's
gonna be disruptive people won't like it
I'll be distracted not gonna like it
I'll eat it for you okay you promise the
few seconds ago that we should probably
cook it for him they're gonna pull that
sponsor real quick when he starts
vomiting
[Laughter]
so if flight was delayed after woman
brings emotional support squirrel on
plane surprisingly we've talked about
emotional support animal stories before
yeah I guess it's a plan people are
trying to get away with this woman
tried to bring the stop and it allows
disruption they had to evacuate everyone
else mmm it reminds me like remember
earlier this week we talked about like
the gas station that they're like please
stop microwaving your pee here it's that
these like airlines have to make their
rules so specific so people don't bring
wild animals on the plane I'm just crazy
a little bit is not a black woman and
we'll go to hope for the best
Chris I've got some good news for you
throw that video not a black woman he's
a crazy old
[Applause]
baby stories you just know you don't
want to assume but you know the police
escorting her off the police escorting
op she refused to leave she throws the
bird some people applause which she
interprets it in favor of her so she
throws a thumbs up although those are
other people who have been forced to
leave this plane and have their flight
delayed for two hours so the applause
might just be we're glad you're gone
Thank You Gillian and also this is in
Orlando and there's so many kids like
either leaving or like probably leaving
Disneyworld that are just like can we go
home and they're like no there's a
squirrel woman on the plane all the
animals to bring on a plane
squirrel is perfect what do you get on
an airplane peanuts they come at you
they're not afraid of people available
DLO Hobbs yeah they let you know I'm
coming I guess you've never seen Alvin
and the Chipmunks you know I don't want
to say you know what animal are they
squirrels
yeah and if this show is sponsored by
chipmunks I'll kiss one every
you heard it here look how wow they are
look at sponsored by chipmunks I will
immature you guys just discovered that
there are my best friends this is Jordan
confessed and in the office the other
day to be like man it'd be so cool if
like we all got a house together some
places it could be affordable it could
be reasonable you can bring your wives
and stuff I wanna sleep in DC news first
bat woman Ruby Rose showed a first look
of her tan character as Batwoman show
that photo this is from her Instagram
account whoa pretty cool I mean that's a
pic that's a cartoon mm-hmm what is that
that's not a what the cleavage I want
that forward to be more like a dress no
I like guys like George Clooney feels
like that era yeah that's yeah I agree
with Mr Freeze is somewhere around that
yeah what's the difference between DC
movie in a moment like what's one comic
book yeah but like what's given ample
okay so DC would be like Superman bat
and those guys like Captain Marvel which
is weird spider-man doesn't be like if
comedies and had a show called Captain
Marvel does that mean that spider-man
can't be in a movie with Superman yes
absolutely they're two different kind of
book worlds yeah you know each atomic
please no one's cry like they crossed
over it so because none of it is real
[Laughter]
lesbian and get her period I do have a
shoutout so yesterday we played slap the
bag thanks to Hannah and I made a I lost
and but on Tuesday we talked about most
embarrassing drinking games and my
favorite response to that question came
from H torero and he said devil's
triangle which we all know is a very
popular drinking game and not at all
some weird sex thing that may have been
lied about under oath right now hi I'm
Hannah Dickinson and this is cheers to
you where I'm kicking off my first round
of the weekend by cheering all the
people and stories that encouraged me to
drink cheers to Republicans for losing
your sweetheart Taylor Swift still in
contention our mama June Kanye West and
an ak-47
[Music]
cheers see you Kim Kardashian for
photoshopping your eyes to make them
lighter while you're at it why don't you
open them to your husband's false sense
of reality cheers to you beer for
lowering life expectancy by consuming
just one a day or should I say Brett
Brett Brett Brett Brett Brett finish it
yeah cheers new lacroix for using
cockroach insecticide in your natural
water
the only thing natural about lacroix is
that it's an American company based in
lies and the only thing French about
Lacroix is that it stinks cheers to you
men for running out of sperm there goes
my protein Cheers I really do want to
have this taste test I'm not gonna cook
the dish or no one because I know then
you'll know but hey so a frozen to join
over some Little Caesars yeah I don't
think you'll be able to tell the
difference maybe it's also important to
register to vote tomorrow being the
deadline in most states for the DiGiorno
little seeds they really just throw you
bitches oh oh I think I couldn't tell if
it was like Little Caesars versus Doc so
I would know every single one by by just
by looking at it which I wouldn't be
able to name it because you have frozen
pizza every single night I love frozen
bet $100 Blanco that I could tell the
difference between Little Caesars
Domino's Pizza Hut DiGiorno's I can tell
you which one was which with one bite
and you have to bite the crust first so
do you bite the piece of not crafts just
one bite you know if I crush I can tell
the difference I could do that too of
saying I can do it we if we all lived in
a house together we could do this
let's make an Avenue thanks for watching
please like comment subscribe see you
next time
[Music]